[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga coming to you from the heart of
Berlin Oh Germany's two biggest
political parties are currently trying
to forge a new coalition government the
problem is though that Angela Merkel's
Conservatives and the Social Democrats
both suffered historic losses in last
September's election and it's the same
picture in much of the rest of Europe
where traditional broad-based parties
are increasingly coming under pressure
from brash and often aggressive populist
parties who win voters over by offering
simple solutions to complex problems so
how should the mainstream parties
respond and can they survive so I
questioned on quadriga
this week europe's far-right can the
established parties stop them and to
discuss that question i'm joined here in
the studio by matthew carnage nik chief
europe correspondent for Politico he
says Europe's populist Tsar here to stay
if traditional mainstream parties fail
to reinvent themselves soon it's only a
matter of time before the fringe
supplants them also with this to sell
and pose an economist with the Berlin
Daily de Velde who argues that political
parties alone can't stop the rise of the
far-right civil society from trade
unions to soccer clubs needs to rally
around liberal democracy and a very warm
welcome to to Sheryl Dean Schwarz she's
a French German journalist who's just
published a book about the role of her
family under the Nazis and Geraldine
says the emergence of Europe's far-right
populist s' is linked to the way in
which individual European countries have
since the Second World War tried or not
tried to come to terms with their
history all very interesting stuff I'm
going to begin with you Alan Alan Posner
and it was just a couple of days ago
that the far-right alternative for
Germany party here in Germany for a
moment at least actually overtook in the
opinion polls one of the main stream
parties here the broad-based parties the
Social Democrats I know that that was
really just a snapshot but it was an
interesting moment and I wondered what
your thoughts were are about that moment
well it's I mean it's sad for you know
the Social Democratic Party which is the
old
party in Germany the only party in
Germany which can trace its history back
to before the Second World War the party
that stood up to Hitler in the high stag
and and said no when Hitler gave himself
dictatorial powers and so on you know
the party of Aleppo hunt and what
happened and how much made well that's
I'm not a fan of helmets but yes so it's
it's it's really it's it's really sad
it's not the sad thing isn't that the
AFD the far-right AFD got gets run out
15% 16% in polls the sad thing is that a
party which represents sort of the broad
working-class in in the broader sense or
should represent them is down to that
segment so yeah it's sad but the as
Matthew said in his statement they have
to reinvent themselves but I I mean
we've discussed this a lot of times if I
knew how I'd probably be the leader of
the Social Democrats not just a
journalist Mathew answer that in just a
second by Matthew I mean the alternative
for Germany now is looking set to become
the main opposition party here in
Germany they're certainly in the
Bundestag we know that Time magazine
wrote in in its most recent edition the
meet the established parties meanwhile
are in free fall
why are they in free fall I think one of
the reasons especially with the Social
Democrats is that they are to a degree
victims of their own success and when
you look back and you know as this sort
of nostalgic lens as Alan has done and
talked about the pre-war period and so
forth in the 19th century when these
parties started they were pushing for
things like universal health care
pensions retirement pensions and and you
know these kinds of things all of which
have been realized so they're not really
the party of the working class anymore
that they once were because they've
helped lift people out of the working
class into the middle class with things
like free university education free
education writ large so I think that you
know they've had difficulty you know not
just recently but really since the
Berlin Wall fell down to adapt to this
new world which has become
more globalized more liberalized and so
forth but you said at the beginning that
the the Social Democrats nevertheless
despite everything you just said need to
reinvent themselves the Christian
Democrats Angela Merkel's Conservatives
need to reinvent themselves to how
against the backdrop of what you've just
been telling us well I would argue that
maybe the Christian Democrats don't need
to reinvent themselves I think that we
might be moving to a situation and in
Germany and maybe some other European
countries what are you going to have one
centrist party and that the Social
Democrats will become just another niche
party because they've also over the
years they've spawned other smaller
parties like the Greens for example the
linka obviously when they had the this
split in Germany in the early 2000s so I
I don't know that that the the
center-right is going to need to
reinvent itself I think the the bigger
problem is what happens on the left or
the bigger question is are you gonna
have sort of a union of these leftist
parties in in Germany and some other
countries because for now the the
center-right seems to be sitting pretty
they did lose a bit in the last election
but they're still over 30% and there's
no reason to think that they you know
that they can't sort of regroup with
with with the right leadership because
their message really does speak more to
these middle classes and you know they
they have shown also organizationally
that they can maintain power and govern
in a very effective way
let's bring Geraldine and Gerald you've
been wrong as I mentioned early been
writing a book about the role of your
family under the Nazis and this at the
same time as we're seeing the rise of
the populist far-right parties across
Europe in many different countries
that's a difficult mixture what are your
feelings given that well I think I mean
my concern is more the rising distrust
against towards democracies because
nothing new has been invented in the
last 70 years after the war so the
result of it is that the distrust of
democracy leads to a kind of nostalgia
feeling towards what was before the
democracy of post-world War two and this
is a fascism and neo and
and National Socialism and my feeling of
course as a French and German person is
that the the light of the world where
where I've been brought up the freedom
democracy Europe has been in freedom for
70 years and this is something people
are forgetting this is something that
was allowed by also the way Europe dealt
with its past after World War Two and
now my feeling is that there's consensus
towards history is is is breaking you
know that word you just mentioned the
word forgetting that the your book is
actually called lism knees ich in French
in English I suppose that would be the
amnesiacs or people who have lost their
memory it's just a little bit more about
that and why it's relevant to what we're
talking about well because I think that
the way people dealt with their history
for example Germany allowed Germany to
build up its democracy the democracy of
Germany you can't separate it from the
way Germany dealt with its past so when
you have a party like the AFT which is
attacking this way of dealing with
memory that is fundamentally for the
democracy then in a way this party
attacks also the democracy because the
way of dealing with history in Germany
especially both the people the the
civilians to develop a sense for
individual moral responsibility you pick
up on that Alan well and I'm not really
because I agree totally I mean that
can't say much about that you're totally
right Geraldine that's okay let's go
back to the the alternative for Germany
as we've seen there they are now a
far-right party there in the German
parliament the Bundestag the question is
now how to respond to them and their
presence here is one example in
September 2017 the far-right populist
alternative for Germany became the third
largest party in Germany's Bundestag
they claim to be the only ones who can
preserve Germany the rhetoric is getting
tougher on all side I won't allow any
heckling all the members sitting there
from the aft if they were they'd admit
that they disdain this country and
everything for which it is highly
regarded the world over and respected a
part of this is our owning up to our
past which is the citizens of this
country I am proud of and I want to
shout out to you that our Germany this
Germany is stronger than your hatred
ever will be the speech by greens
representative gem urged Amira to the
Bundestag swiftly went viral on social
media is the force of political
convictions enough to stop the
right-wingers HMOs Damir with passion
and conviction Ellen is not the right
way to stand up to the AFD in the German
parliament definitely and I'm very
grateful quite personally because this
was a debate about a colleague of mine a
German Turkish colleague called Deniz
you chair who was imprisoned for a year
without charges in a Turkish jail and
was released and it was the AFD who
demanded a debate in the German
Bundestag and demanded of the government
that they distance themselves from some
critical remarks UGL had made about the
German government and it was in this
debate and the attempt was simply to set
up the Bundestag as the the German
parliament as a sensor agency for
journalism and in this debate I think
jammers de vere who like Deniz UGL is a
German of German Turkish origin showed
them where they get off and in no
uncertain terms and I think was very
good that we had a member of the Green
Party which sort of are traditionally
have been wary of German patriotism
generally speaking really using
patriotic language to show that in fact
the AFT the right-wingers actually do
hate everything that post-war Germany
stands for as indeed the Stephane Astana
in
as indeed do the right-wingers in in
Poland that they they hate this new
Germany this new Europe and and I was I
thought I thought bad you know I'm not
not a generally speaking here someone
who was tends to represent green
opinions but I thought the Jim as Timmy
I made a I mean he was the only one in
that debate who really had the fire to
combat dfd is the danger not that if you
start getting fiery and combative in
that way that it becomes a shouting
match in the German parliament nothing
well I think you know that's obviously a
danger and I think Germany given the
Divine Mary history and so forth might
be particularly sensitive to that
although I found it refreshing that for
once there was real debate going on
there was a real exchange of ideas and
viewpoints I do think and I thought that
this speech was very important because
it sent a very clear message I would add
though that I think that Soumya was
really preaching to the choir in a way I
don't know that he convinced many AFD
voters of his side I thought it was
important because he is Alan said sort
of redefined German patriotism in his
own terms and said this is what it means
to be German not what you think it means
to be German but I think that the larger
problem here is that the AFD you know
continues to get 15 16 percent in the
polls and the same as in other countries
and it's because of this issue of
migration of refugees that the
established parties you know going back
to what we were talking about before why
the SPD can't really reinvent itself at
the moment I think that this issue of
migration is at the core of it because
they have traditionally been an
internationalist party they're very open
to asylum to taking in refugees of all
kinds and they wouldn't have any
credibility were they to reverse their
position on that and this is where I
think the center-right has had a bit of
an advantage particularly if you look at
Austria now under Sebastian coup it's
has obviously been very very out front
in strengthening the asylum rules there
but even in Germany I mean Merkel has
this reputation as being the mother of
all refugees but in fact if you look at
what the CDU has done over the past
of years in tightening Asylum rules it's
been quite extraordinary so I think this
is sort of a fundamental issue that is
bubbling beneath the surface still that
is the the biggest challenge that the
left-leaning parties have mm-hmm just to
come back to assume your speech I think
of course he doesn't convince the
hardcore voters of aad aft but maybe he
convinced the other ones he confused the
Social Democrats who are now voting aft
because people need also emotion and I
think someone like s Damir and this kind
of debate gives fuels a bit the debate
with emotions and this is very important
nowadays because nowadays only the
populist parties are giving this emotion
so we need more emotions from the power
of the other parties and but I don't
find this debate I didn't find this
debate very interesting because I found
it actually very depressing that in
Germany today we have in 2018 a debate
on freedom of speech and of press this
is we are going back we're talking about
going back I mean people are so people
are suddenly talking a lot about pride
people are talking about identity people
talk about nation-states rather than
rather than social groupings people
there's even been a call for a
conservative revolution where's all that
coming from suddenly I'm not totally
against a sense of pride you you can be
proud of your country I think Germany
maybe this was a bit too long a taboo
that you are not allowed to be proud of
this of the country and so I think it's
a this is not linked for me to nostalgia
of of the past but we have to build it
on a very clear basis which is the basis
of being proud of the German
constitution the German democracy what
Germany has done since 45 you know and
not and against immigration or against
the other based nationalism L&R
far-right populist part
is now part of the mainstream across
Europe well as you as you said they've
actually managed to redefine the debate
even someone like Gemma's Tamia when he
comes on the bonus arc he talks he uses
the language the the the form of
language patriotism love of country
which let's face it let's hand it to
them the the right-wing populist
introduced into the debate the problem
here is that this is part of a worldwide
trend we've got Russia basically playing
19th century great power politics
we've got President Trump saying America
first which basically means you know
that none of the rules binding
international organizations and
countries together that they're simply
deals way and bad or good deals
we got breaks we've got Britain's people
saying we want to take control of our
country again as if that were possible
in the 21st century and now we've got
within Europe the Visigoths groups
Eastern Europe countries Hungary saying
they don't want closer integration you
want less integration and it then we've
got the populist here so it's obviously
this weekend so we're entering you know
we're being dragged kicking and
screaming as people who believe in the
liberal world order into a much less
liberal world disorder and it's a
frightening it's frightening quite
frankly okay so could this be the
beginning of a populist era that's one
question another is could it be the era
of charismatic politicians leaders not
of parties but of popular movements
people like in money well in macro in
France and we've mentioned him already
Sebastian courts in Austria high
expectations were riding on Emmanuel
macron when he took the French
presidency and the European stage he'd
founded the on marsh party especially
for the election swiftly gathering
hundreds of thousands of supporters and
millions of voters with his power of
persuasion and pro-european direction it
was enough to win against Marie lepen
and her right-wing populist front nación
ah
sebastien ports - is a party platform on
two legs the conservative Austrian
People's Party made the charismatic
politician their chairman he set out on
the campaign trail with his court's
ticket it was open to non-party members
as well he left behind the right-wing
populist FPO but then included them in
his coalition do mock wrong and courts
embody a new political culture for
Europe
[Music]
that's the question Matthew Emmanuel
macron Sebastian courts today represents
the new European politics I think they
do in some countries and we've seen that
in other places as well I don't think
coach the strategy is that different
from say Viktor orbán's
in Hungary that said you know courts is
obviously much younger he's a
fresh-faced is the interesting thing
about courts is that he did this within
an established party the FL pay the
Austrian People's Party has been in
power often as a junior partner but has
been in the government coalition in
Austria since 1987 so it's kind of it's
really an extraordinary thing when you
talk about this backlash against the
establishment that there's somebody you
know he's about 30 years old comes in it
sort of changes the name of the party
calls it the Sebastian courts list and
so forth and manages to pull this up and
how did he pull it off it was because he
used the same tools that the populace
use he used the same sort of media tools
that they've used and he also stole
their main theme which is again
migration fear of refugees but is that
then one strategy against the far-right
that could be adopted by other parties
across Europe about perhaps even by
Germany but then they become a far-right
which is what they say that they don't
want to do and this way this this
question of credibility comes in that's
why I think it's difficult for the
center-left parties to copy that
strategy because they don't have the
same credibility if if say the SPD were
to come out and say well we want to
enact really strict rules on on asylum
and and immigration they wouldn't have
the credibility because for the past 70
years they've been preaching something
else and I think you've seen that for
example in Italy where there is this
election this weekend Matteo Renzi was
also sort of hailed as this McConnell
like figure very popular young guy was
going to reform everything and make
everything better and they're probably
going to get around 20% on Sunday so
it's not just the personality there are
other factors there that really are
important hmm is it is it possible that
in German politics there could be
somebody like yeah and spam the angry
young man of conservative politics could
look to how Sebastian courts has been
doing things and think that's that's one
way to go or it's that inconceivable in
German politics no no I mean I'm as
Matthew said I think the Christian
Democrats angle America's strategy
was to move the Christian Democrats to
the left because when she started in
that strategy they were worried that the
that the Christian Democrats we would be
marginalized the Social Democrats would
take the center
she managed that opened up a position on
the right onions span for instance would
move the Christian Democrats back to the
right trying to squeeze out the aft he
might manage though he himself I think
is a bit of a lightweight person you
know sort of a Twitter personality
rather than what but anyway yes that's
where it could go but it can go in
different directions look at Great
Britain look at Jeremy Corbyn with a
left-wing populist message challenging
theories am a and look at what might be
happening in United States look whether
Democrats are now you're advocating
universal health care and things which
you know a decade ago in America would
have been rated socialism so you know
it's on both sides of the political
divide that that people are ramping up
the populist message
Geraldine Huerta so where does a man
welcome McCarron fit into all this
left-right the battle against popular or
right-wing populist and what can we
learn from him well I mean actually he
was he's the big winner also because of
the electoral system in France which
allows it and in Germany would not be
possible because of the electoral system
this is the first point and the second
is also his ruling in a quiet auto auto
retiree in a way in German in France and
I'm not sure in Germany the government
or a team would allow this kind of
authoritarian rule but it is true that
he now the for national is totally down
and I think it's it's been it's at its
lowest in the 10 last years and but it
doesn't mean it's for forever
done no so if he fails if micro fails
then the first party of France will be
the fullness you know I think that's an
important point that these parties they
sometimes go down in the polls and then
you know the sort of commentary at
people like us say oh well that's the
end of populism
if you watch it over the past few
decades that certainly hasn't been the
case they're sort of dormant for a while
it's sort of like cancer that goes into
remission and then and then comes back
when when there's a problem and you saw
this in Germany with the AFD as well
which when they were having their
internal struggles a few years ago fell
into the low single digits and as soon
as the refugee crisis came I think by
the end of that year they were around
10% and they obviously finished the 12%
in the last poll so I I think the
problem with these parties is that once
they take hold in the system as the AFD
has done now in the Bundestag it's very
difficult to get rid of them mmm and if
this is one great big battle island
between the established mainstream
parties the broad-based parties that
have been part of the post-war
settlement right across Europe a battle
between them and between the new young
populist parties who's gonna win not
well so it's more than that it's a
battle between the Liberals World Order
and the illiberal
World Disorder and I think it's in the
back and let's not forget behind the
illiberal order you've got Russia
you've got China you've got great powers
you've got Islamism and you've got the
populist things it you know it's in the
balance it's it's a fight it's not you
know it's why do so many people tempted
by the illiberal order and tempted to
shift away from democracy because
they've forgotten how it looks like when
there is no democracy because they
haven't lived it you know because the
white 70 years a ago so you know we have
to remind people again and again I think
so no I agree I mean I think this this
this idea about the nostalgia of the
past people tend to sort of mythologize
the past especially a past that they
didn't experience which is why I think
this book is sort of interesting this
people collectively forget how it really
was but at the same time you know it
does appear that there is a large swathe
of the population in Europe and in in
the West in the US as well that is just
not happy culturally with the way things
have moved over the past 30 years or so
with globalization with you know
increased immigration in all of these
countries and that's not going to change
okay and the best way to come back the
far right in one sentence in a nutshell
is to do I think what is demure is done
which is to confront them head on and to
not not hide from the debate to take
them head-on with real argument yeah
yeah yeah make democracy sexy again make
democracy sexy yeah I agree
oh and remind also that democracy is
also work for citizens citizens have to
participate much more in political life
ok thank you for all that all three of
you thank you for being here today we've
been talking about europe's far-right
can the established party stop them
thanks for joining us come back next
week bye bye inches
[Music]